these turkeys aren't going to enjoy a
long life but their short time on earth
will be enjoyable ugliest Sigler insists
on it his daily routine includes
ensuring his 3,000 turkeys have clean
water and fresh straw their ultimate
fate is sealed however after five months
he'll be sent to slaughter the comma
hoof in southwest Germany is considered
a model poultry farm the free-range
turkeys are not injected with hormones
and the idea of them being washed in a
chlorine bath as sometimes happens in
the u.s. is abhorrent to Ziegler he's
skeptical about other practices across
the Atlantic by the D license photo ID
dodging and the growth enhancers found
in feed there have been banned for
decades here on top of that they have
high stocking densities td5 here you can
see the turkeys roaming free they're
happy and if they're happy so are we
done it's my help to feed comma wolf has
its own store where turkey and other
meat are sold it costs more than in
German discount stores but many
customers are prepared to pay for
quality still many poultry farmers fear
that if the TTIP trade agreement between
the US and EU comes to pass they won't
be able to compete with cheap American
goods
Sigler has a kindred spirit just a few
hours north of kama hoof phoenix
cleanser Levenstein has transformed his
family farm in odin fight into a
thriving organic business he's a strong
critic of industrial farming and the
proposed free trade agreement with the
US he says that small farmers in
particular will suffer from the influx
of cheap imported goods
yamir the product default on the more
products come from places where they can
be produced as cheaply as possible the
more regional economic cycles collapse
that's the flip side of globalization on
a regional and global scale for months
the specter of the TTIP has been
haunting Germany's fields Levenstein and
many other farmers are calling for EU
regulations to be upheld
they say that high farm standards
especially regarding the use of hormones
and chemicals have to be maintained
the German farmers association in Berlin
says that all products have to be
subjected to the same standards
including those from the US the sister
spring that's the crux of the matter
I know sites these conditions reflect
the demands of the European market but
also to some extent those of politicians
and society we will of course have to
make compromises but we see these as
being in terms of market exists not
standards marks or gangs or niched
embellish their standards prints
Levenstein can only agree he represents
the organic farming sector on the German
government's Committee on the free trade
agreement he's annoyed by all the
secrecy min about the important where we
ask concrete questions
what about GM technology or chlorinated
chickens we're told that has nothing to
do with it but nobody says what it does
have to do with the food that leads one
to believe that people are totally
against the agreement like the Durbin
Stein's many farmers are following the
negotiations very closely
critics hope that the proposed EU US
free trade agreement will never come
into existence